Tức anh cảm ơn rồi, của biết đây cái gì?
Anh biết
Em, anh có đặc mạnh
Ừ
Mình dùng cái nào em biết
Mình cái nào nhỏ?
Năm một chính sấu tư
Mý tạo làm một cái sự kẹn rồi là việc mắt mộ
Để kớ ném mơ mình mắt
Chúng không quành tạm tất cả tình lần tận
Súng quành hả nổ rồi
Còn nên là người dân hả nổ người dân tổ đồ lúc nào
Sống trong sẵn thái là
Để cao phải ra
Mộ khi là có tiếng mề bài ngán thì
Vậy thì các cái chua nổ chua đúng không?
Mình chất cái dây bài đấy thì
Nhà mẹ cơ kia nội đã sẽ tạo là chứ có gì thế này, khi giám như bạn đến chung mà có lạng đặc biệt sống
Đấy, khi nó u lên thì các cả người dân là xong thành phố điều ngày đấy tiếng
Đấy, và sẽ tìm cách để chui xuống nơi chúa and ăn vàn nhất
Bảo cảng có chung bài mình chính tranh khóa, hay chỉ tổ lột cô
Nhưng thế là có giữa ăn, bảo cảng hành động như chứ rất nhiều những vật và tư liệu là mỏ người hành động của các phụ chứ chanh
Tư hành xin chung pháp này, chung nghĩ này đến những ngày nào hòa bình và đây không chỉ là lịch sử của nó sự
Mà đây có là lịch sử của những con người thương ngày, phóng in phải sống những cái chanh
Chến tranh ở hành động khác chế chưởng thế nào?
Hmm, khác đấy
Với đi hành động là khủ đô, bữa làm một tiêu của là hậu phương
Và trong người 2 ngày đêm, thả bóng mấy năm 2, nha của mình chỉ cho mẹn hải
Với hành động vừa sư tả hình như đường sạm sất vừa chiến đấu
Điều sụ thế hậu trộn và bất đứa có người môi hậu bài dễ nghen đấu trong hầm
Với đi hậu ti là sẽ có một người hành hoa bình để dụng nè cái cái đó
Hết và tự nào ở đây là mạnh chỉ xúc lọng nhất
Đối với mình là chứ khóa bói bói bói bói này
Lần trong mình còn ghi cảm xúc nó rất là đặc biệt
Thêm xong mình nghĩ hòa bình là điều không phải tự nhiên mà có
Đúng là thế mà
Vậy thì hẹn gặp lại bạch tại màu tả hành động
Nơi chiến tranh màu hòa bình cùng đồn gại trong những người bất và nhắc tán giữa là
Mà đi cùng đây là có đặc biệt
Thả bất kêu là có bạch nha
Thà chứa nhá
Chúng như phò lâu cây chúng mình tiếp tục hảm phán
Cú bảo khách năng ở chỗ tại màu tả hành động
Cú bảo đây được khi nó không phải là những người bất chúng đặc biệt
Nhìn thấy phà sau để được phúc bảo này
Có thể chỉ trả những cái kỳc
Cực kỳ bảo, quý giá
Nhưng người trả này chúng ta nên được biết đến
Hãy subscribe
Chúng ta